اذا بالفعل المشاهدين اهلا بكم مستمرون
معكم في تغطيه الحدث الابرز هذه الليله
زلزالا جديدا اذا مركزهما وسط انطاكيا
مركز ولايه هاتاي جنوب تركيا وشعر بهما
سكان سوريا ولبنان وفلسطين والاردن وصولا
الى مصر الزلزال الاول بلغت شدته 6.4
درجات جنوب تركيا بالقرب من الحدود
السوريه اما زلزال الثاني فبلغت شدته 5.8
درجات مما تسبب في حاله من الذعر والحاق
المزيد من الاضرار بالمباني المتهالكه
وهذا بعد اسبوعين فقط من اسوا زلزال تشهد
البلاد في التاريخ الحديث والذي اودى
بحياه عشرات الالاف اذا مشاهدينا نتحدث عن
زلزلين جديدين
الى تدمير المزيد من المباني المتهالكه
اذا وذكر مركز رصد الزلازل الاوروبيه
المتوسطي ان مركز الزلزال كان على عمق
كيلومترين وكاله الاناضول التركيه نقلت عن
النائب الرئيس التركي قوله ان ثمانيه
اشخاص اصيبوا بجروح عقب الزلزلين
رئيس بلديه هدايا قال ايضا انه تلقى
تقارير عن اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض بعد
هذين الزلزلين الجديدين كما نشد نائب رئيس
التركي كذلك الجميع بعدم التوجه او الدخول
الى المباني في المدن المتضرره جراء
الزلزال كذلك مشاهدينا في هذا الخبر
العاجل وزاره التعليم اللبنانيه تعلن غلق
المدارس والجامعات غدا بسبب الهزه الارضيه
اذا هذه الاخيره هذه الليله اذن واثارت
حالتها من الذعر كذلك في لبنان الناس هرعت
في مناطق في لبنان الى الشوارع خوفا من
هذه الهزه الجديده حركه الطيران توقفت في
مطار هاتاي التركي بعد الزلزلين الجديدين
كذلك اذا مشاهدينا مركز الزلزلين الجديدين
هذه المره هو محافظه هاتاي كما ذكرنا
عاصمتها هي مدينه انطاكيا في جنوب تركيا
تبلغ مساحتها حوالي 56878 كيلومترا مربعا
هاتاي كانت تعرف باسم لواء اسكندرون حتى
عام حين اقتطع هذا اللواء من الاراضي
السوريه ايام الانتداب الفرنسي على سوريا
وتم ضمه الى تركيا اذا في متابعه اذا
للمشاهد لهذين الزلزالين الجديدين اظهرت
لقطات فيديو مصوره اللحظات الاولى لانهيار
مبانئ في مدينه انطاكيا التركيه مركز
ولايه هاتاي بعد تعرضها لزلزال جديد اثار
حاله من الهلع بين سكان المدينه الذي
تركوا منازلهم بحثا عن اماكن امنه نشاهد
الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
نبدا المتابعه مع موفادنا الى اذيه مع
محمود شكر محمود اهلا بك الصوره عندك الان
محمود شكر تسمعني
طيب نعم نعم
الصوره عندك محمود لو سمحت
نعم نحن في هذه المدينه ساذهب معك بهذه
الصوره مباشره من داخل احياء مدينه عايدي
ونحن امام مركز الوالي الاساسي ايضا
بالاضافه الى كل هذه الشوارع التي نشاهد
فيها وبها حركه شبه اعتياديه مثل الايام
الماضيه المساله الاولى كانت عندما وقعت
الهزه وليست كما نقول وبدانا هزه
الارتداديه هي هزه قائمه بحد ذاتها
وبطبيعتها وايضا احدث نوع من الهلع
والتوتر في ذلك لكن هذا زلزال جديد اخذ
جديد
6.45
عقبتهما حوالي 16 هزه ارتداديه طيب حدثني
كيف شعرت ما مدى قوه الهزتين الجديدتين
محمود الزلزالان الجديدين
كذلك كيف شعرت بهما في اديمان
نعم نحن بطبيعه الحال كنا خارج
المخيم وكنا على الارض يعني بطبيعه الحال
كنا مثل ملان نحن نتواجد جوله خارج المخيم
وداخل المدينه حقيقه على المستوى الشخصي
شعرت بدوخه لحوالي عشرين ثانيه وشعرت ان
الارض تتحرك ثم بعد ذلك علمت الى انها هي
هزه لان بعض الابنيه نحن نتواجد في
الشوارع بعض الابنيه اصبح بها بعض الاصوات
ولكنها لم تؤدي الى عمليه وقوع او الى
عمليه زحزحه ما ان كانت الامور خلال 20
الى 30 ثانيه كانت على وسريعا على وسائل
التواصل تاتي وعلى الهواتف الى ان هذه
الهزه هي عذرا الان وزير الداخليه التركي
يؤكد نقله 213 مصابا الى المستشفيات جراء
الزلزلين الاخيرين في هاتاي جنوب تركيا
اذا الحصيله ترتفع من المصابين لا قتل حتى
الان جراء الزلزال الجديد اذا هذه الليله
مشاهدينا في جنوب تركيا ووزير الداخليه
اذا يؤكد نقل 213 مصابا كذلك في سوريا
الذين شعروا يعني في المناطق السوريه كذلك
كان هناك ثلاثه قتلى اين في تركيا اذا
الان خبر عاجل المشاهدين ايضا هذا التطور
الان ثلاثه قتله للاسف اذا كنا نتحدث على
علاقه في الزلزال الجديد الان يخبرني
الزملاء في غرفه اخبار العربيه الى ثلاثه
قتله اذا سقطوا جراء هذا الزلزال الجديد
هذه الليله مركزه اذن في انطاكيا مركز
ولايه هاتاي في جنوب تركيا على الحدود
السوريه 213 مصابا وثلاثه قتلى هذه حصيله
جديده اذا وصلتنا للتو
التسجيل 26 هزه ارتداديه اذا معلومات
جديده ينقلها وزير الداخليه التركي 26 هزه
ارتداديه جديده منذ وقوع الزلزال الجديد
في هاتاي جنوب تركيا مشاهدينا اعود واذكر
ان الزلزال الجديد احدث حاله هلعن ورعب
كبيرين ان كان في المناطق التركيه وكذلك
في سوريا خصوصا وفي لبنان والاردن وفلسطين
ووصولا الى مصر هناك بعض الشهادات التي
وثقت حتى في مصر هناك من شعر بهذا الزلزال
الجديد الحصيله اذا ثلاثه قتله
الان 213 مصابا في تركيا جراء الزلزلين
الجديدين اذا شدتهما 6.4 ثم زلزال اخر
بخمسه فاصل
ثماني درجات على مقياس
ايضا صور من ريف ادلب اذن بعد وقوع
الزلزال نتابعها معكم
صور من ريف ادلب نعم للصور الاوليه بعد
وقوع الزلزال طبعا الناس هرعت الى الشوارع
واستذكر طبعا لحظات الرعب قبل اسبوعين في
زلزال السادس من فبراير الزلزال المدمر
الذي كان مركزه كرمان مرعش في تركيا اما
زلزال اليوم فهو قريب اكثر الى المناطق
السوريه هو في
ولايه هاتاي التي كانت تعرف سابقا ايام
الانتداب الفرنسي لواء اسكندرون كانت هي
جزء طبعا من الاراضي السوريه كان حتى عام
1939 ثم ضمتها تركيا الى اراضيها طبعا
حاله ذعر كبيره كان هناك حديث عن تسجيل
عدد من المصابين ليس لدينا رقم نهائي بعد
طبعا سقوط بعض الابنيه
المتهالكه او الايل للسقوط التي كانت
تضررت بسبب السادس من فبراير نشاهد هذه
الصور من شوارع اذا ريف ادلب الناس هرعت
الى سياراتها اذن وخرجت الى الشوارع خوفا
من تكرار السيناريو فرق الانقاذ الى ان
تواصل عملها في المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال الجديد يقول وزير الداخليه تركي
محمود اعود اليك عذرا كنت مضطر لمقاطعتك
لنقل هذه الحصيله الجديده ثلاثه قتله اذن
و213 مصابا حتى الان في الزلزال الجديد
هذه الليله في هاتاي كنت تتحدث عن ما شعرت
به حوالي 20 ثانيه من الزلزال حدثني عن
حاله الهلع هل ما تزال مستمر الان في
اليمن ام عادت الامور الى طبيعتها قليله
نعم لا توجد حاله حاله من الهلع في هذا
التوقيت انما هي حاله من الخوف الخوف
المجهول بالتوتر وخوفا من ان تعود هزات
الافتداديه من جديد ولكن في هذه المدينه
المساله تختلف اختلافا كليا لربما عن
المدن الاخرى وهنالك ايضا غرابه في هاتايب
الاعداد الكبيره لماذا لان جل الناس
اكثرهم هم خارج المدينه هم خارج البنايات
السالمه او المتصدعه هم لم يعودوا الى
مساكنهم هم انتقلوا اليها الى خارج هذه
المدينه الى القرى والى اقاليم اخرى والى
ولايات اخرى وايضا الباقيه المتبقيه هم
يتواجدون ويبيتون في المخيمات من ذهب الى
منزله او سمحت له السلطات هو عباره عن
منزل من طابقين فقط لا اكثر البنايات لا
احد يسكنها على طول هذا الشارع الذي نحن
فيه هو المركز الرئيسي للمدينه
بعض الوقت يعني كانت القوات العسكريه هنا
في هذه الزوايا بالاضافه الى الشرطه كما
نشاهدها عند زاويه المدخل خرجت قوه كبيره
من الجيش وانتشرت في الشوارع بالاضافه
ايضا سجل حركه طائرات في السماء المدينه
وايضا حركه تاهب لفرق الدفاع المدني وايضا
في الدفاع المدني وللهلال الاحمر التركي
كما نشاهد الان مجموعه من المتطوعين هم
على جانب الان يقفون امامنا على جانب هذا
الطريق
للاسعافاتها تستقبل اي مصاب حتى الان
محمود امن لا يمكن الجزم بذلك
الجديد اذا الى سبعه واربعين شخصا اذا
لدينا حصله جديده اذا محدثه من حلب في
سوريا اذا 47 مصاب جراء الهزتين الجديتين
مركزهما كان كما ذكرت هذه الليله
ولايه اتاي ومركزها انطاكيا سابقا هي لواء
اسكندرون كان جزءا من الاراضي السوريه حتى
عام 39 قبل ان تضمها تركيا اليها الحصيله
في تركيا اكثر ثلاثه قتله للاسف جراء
الهزتين الجديتين اذا واكثر من 213 مصابا
في الاراضي التركيه اذا نعود محمود سكتفي
معك بهذا القدر الان نحن في متابعه معكم
اذا هذه صور مره اخرى من ادلب كذلك
المناطق السوريه يعني كان تاثرت كذلك
بالزلزال الجديد بشكل كبير جدا بالنظر الى
القرب الجغرافي لمركز هذه الجديده زلزال
السادس من فبراير كان مركزه ولايه كرمان
مرعش في جنوب تركيا ولكن كانت ابعد قليلا
من هاتاي هاتاي اقرب بكثير الى
الحدود السوريه
وطبعا تاثرت به عديد المناطق السوريه كذلك
في لبنان شعراء السكان
وغادر السكان منازلهم نعم
وكذلك في الاردن وفلسطين ووصولا الى مصر
معنى الان من حلب من ريف حلب احمد ابو لؤي
معنا في هذه التغطيه ينضم الينا احمد اهلا
بك معنا النظام السوري يتحدث عن 47 مصاب
في حلب
اكثر من 30 اصابه في فصيله طبعا غير
نهائيه غالبيتها بغالبيتها بحالات كسور
ردود وحالات اغماء وخوف وهلع طبعا
الان على اسعاف المصابين الى المشافي والى
المستوصفات وتفقد اوضاع القرى والبلدات
الحقيقه احمد انا اشكرك على هذا التحديث
معلومه مهمه جدا
اعود انوه الى العجل بات الان اذا على
شاشه العربيه اذا القواد البيضاء تؤكد 130
مصابا في شمال غرب سوريا حتى الان جراء
الزلزال الاخير يعني نتحدث عن مناطق شمال
غرب سوريا المناطق غير الخاضعه للسيطره
النظام ونتابع معكم في هذه الصور من ريف
حلب وشاهدوا معنا مشاهدينا حاله الهلع هذه
الصور من حلب اذن صور من حلب لحاله الهلع
بعد الزلزال شاهدوا السيارات وهي مسرعه
والناس التي خرجت اهل عن وخوفا بعد الهزه
الاخيره نستمع للصوت الطبيعي صور من حلب
بعد الزلزال
هناك صوت في الصور
طيب
يبدو ان الصور يعني الصوت غير متوفر
طيب لا الان نستمع للصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
اذا
حاله خوف باديه طبعا نكد نستشعرها من هنا
طبعا مع بعد وقوع هذين الزلزلين الجديدين
نعود و بكر المشاهدين الخبر الرئيسي هذه
الليله زلزلان جديدان الاول بلغت شدته 6.4
درجات على مقياس سنختر الثاني خمسه فاصل
ثمانيه على مقياس مركزها انطاكيا مركز
ولايه هاتاي في جنوب تركيا على الحدود مع
سوريا الحصيله حتى الان ثلاثه قتله في
تركيا 213 مصابا في تركيا طبعا دائما في
المناطق شمال غرب سوريا اي المناطق غير
الخاضعه على سيطره النظام 130 مصابا كما
تشاهدون على العاجل نقلا عن الدفاع المدني
السوري او الخوذ البيضاء بينما دمش تحدثت
عن 47 مصابا في حلب جراء الزلزال الجديد
احمد ابو لؤي هل ما تزال معي
احمد
احمد هل انت معي
نعم طيب كنا نشاهد صورا لحاله هلع الناس
اطلقت ابواق سياراتها
وتركض في الشوارع في حلب بعد الزلزال هل
ما تزال حاله الخوف ماثله الان عندكم في
ريف حلب
الاف العائلات في الطرقات الان للبحث على
القيام من اجل قضاء هذه الليله درجات
الحراره يعني تحت السفر بثلاثه
تتفاقم اوضاع يشهدها الاف العائلات جراء
الهلع والخوف جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب طبعا
تركيا وكان له تاثير كبير لمناطق شمال
غربي سوريا سواء حلب او في ادلب طبعا كما
ذكرت يعني
الناس جميعها الان في الطرقات منهم من ذهب
الى اقرب الناس يعني ما تزال في الطرقات
الان في الشوارع طبعا نعم نعم بعد هذا
الزلزال الجديد يعني لا احد يعني يجرؤ على
العوده الى منز الان والمبيت هناك طيب نعم
نعم الناس الذين لديهم امكانيات على ما
اعتقد يمكن ان يمضوا الليله في السيارات
صحيح
نعم اعذرني فقط اقاطعك فقط اشير الى هذه
الصور وصلتنا للتو
نشاهد حريقا اذا في احد المباني
اندلع اذا فيها تاي في جنوب تركيا مركز
الزلزال الجديد اذا مشاهدينا نشاهد السنه
اللهب والدخان كذلك تتصاعد من هذا المبنى
الذي يبدو متهالكا يعني ويكاد يكون مدمرا
والنيران اشتعلت فيه طبعا
ينصح في حالات وقوع الهزات الارضيه بقطع
الغاز واي يعني وسيله لاشعال النار
والتدفئه خشيه حدوث حرائق نتابع معكم هذه
الصور
لاندلاع حريق ونشاهد الان خراطيم المياه
في محاوله كذلك لاطفاء هذا الحريق في
الصور من هاتاي من جنوب تركيا مركز
الزلزال الجديد زلزلان مشاهدينا هذا
غسان سويدان رئيس مركزي رصد الزلازل
الاردني استاذ غسان اهلا بك معنا في هذه
التغطيه من العربيه
حدثنا بدايه هل هذا طبيعي يعني بعد حوالي
اسبوعين من الزلزال المدمر في كرمان مرعش
زلزال اخر في مركزه في ولايه هاتاي
جنوبا
بسته فاصل اربعه درجات على مقياس رختر
وبعد زلزال بخمسه فاصل ثمانيه هل هذا
طبيعي
نعم سيدي يمسيك بالخير نرجع بنكمل انه
الصفيحه العربيه تتصادم مع صفيحه الاناضول
انت بتتكلم من اقصى حدود الغربيه
السوريه الى تقريبا 350 كيلو متر شرقا في
في الاراضي التركيه اي ان يعني
عندك 350 الى 400 كيلو متر هاي حدود
صفائحيه بين الصفيحه العربيه والصفيحه
التركيه اذا التصادم هو بيحصل على طول هذه
على طول هذا الخط فانت كان في عنا بالسادس
من فبراير زلازل مجموعه زلازل كبيره زلازل
مدمره ونشهد اليوم مجموعه اخرى من الزلازل
وتكون يعني حدتها وقوتها اخف ان شاء الله
ولكن هذا الشيء طبيعي هو شيء متوقع
علميا ولكن انا يعني هذه علمنا اللي احنا
وصلنا له بس نعم طيب اذا نتحدث اليوم عن
زلزال جديد منفصل عن زلزال السادس من
فبراير مشاهد الفتره الماضيه من هزات
ارتداديه هو كان تابع لزلزال كرمان مراش
الان الزلزال عقبته على ما اعتقد حتى الان
سته عشره تهزا ارتداديه استاذ غسان ما
الفرق بين الزلزال والهزه الارتداديه كيف
يمكن التفريق بينهما
نعم صحيح هلا احنا بنقول هزه ارتداديه
بتكون في تقريبا قريبه من موقع الزلزال
الرئيس ولا تبعد عنه احنا اليوم بنتكلم عن
تقريبا مسافه 250 كيلو متر تقريبا انا ما
بعرف الارقام ميه الميه الان ولكن الزلزال
الحصري اليوم هو يبعد عن الزلزال اللي حصل
بالسادس من فبراير تقريبا 250 كيلو متر
زائد ناقص بعض اي انه زلزال او مصدر نعم
او انه مصدر جديد لسلاسل يعني هاي النقطه
الان اصبحت مصدر جديد لحركات زلزاليه
حديثه نعم استاذ غسان ارجو ان تبقى معي
صور جديده مشاهدينا للحظه الهزه الجديده
من اضنه في تركيا نشاهد
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا هي لحظات مرعبه
لمن يشاهدها واكيد اكثر رعبا لمن يعايشها
بالفعل شاهدوا هذه الخزانه وهي تهتز جيئه
وذهابا وهذه طبعا البيت كله يهتز
جراء هذه هذا الزلزال الجديد الصور اعود
اذكر من اضنه اضنه غير بعيده عن اسكندرون
او عن هاتاي مركز الزلزال الجديد الزلزلين
الجديدين هذه الليله
والحصيله ثلاثه قتله حتى الان للاسف هو
اكثر من 213 مصابا في تركيا وحدها 130
مصاب في شمال غرب سوريا و 47 مصاب في حلب
وحدها في المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره النظام
استاذ غسان عذرا قاطعتك اعود اليك يعني
نشاهد ان يعني هذا الزلزال يبدو ك قويا
واستمر على ما يبدو لعشرين ثانيه
علميا يعني هل يمكن ان يسجل زلزال بهكذا
قوه بعد كل بعد هذه الفتره الوجيزه اعذرني
يعني ان اولحها عليك لان الناس تشعر
بالخوف ومن عايش لحظه الزلزال يبقى خائفا
من ان يتكرر نفس السيناريو هل يمكن ان
يتكرر نفس السيناريو هل هذا علميا وارد
سيدي نعم يعني من حق الناس تخوف يعني ما
شاهدوه هم شاهدوا مناظر رعب في اساس من
فبراير ولا زالوا يشهدوا مناظر رعب ودمار
من الزلازل السابقه فيعني حقهم الطبيعي
انه يخافوا وان شاء الله انه ربنا بيلطف
فيهم اللي حصل اليوم انه هذا زلزال جديد
لا قوه اقل يعني انت لما تتكلم عن زلزال
قوه سته واربعه بالعشره الى زلزال قوه
سبعه وثمانيه بالعشره انت بتتكلم عن
تقريبا 32 ضعف قوه بين السبعه وسته الى
السبعه واربعه فاليوم ان شاء الله انه
بكون اخف واقل ضررا ولا زلنا لانه نشاهد
انه لم افهمها استاذ غسان يعني انه
بيناتهم تقريبا درجه وعشرين يعني كيف انه
هي اكثر من 30 ضعف هلا
طبيعي نعم هلا مقياس الزلازل هو مقياس
لوغاريتمي يعني بيستخدموا في الفرق بين
زلزال قوه خمسه
انه الزلزال قوه سته اكبر من زلزال قوه
خمسه باثنين ضعف انطاق المتحرره من
الزلزال السادس هي اقوى من 32 مره من
الزلزال قوه خمسه وهكذا تواليك فانت
بتتكلم اليوم عن زلزال قوه سته وشويه سته
واربعه بالعشره فهو كثير اخاف من الزلزال
رقم سبعه وثمانيه بالعشره طيب هو زلزال مش
هين صحيح صحيح والان تحديث كنا نتحدث عن
سته عشره هزر ارتداديه تسجيل 26 هزه
ارتداديه منذ وقوع الزلزال الجديد اذا
فيها تاي نقلا عن وزير الداخليه التركي في
هذا العاجل على العربيه طيب استاذ غسان
الهزات الان بالنسبه للزلزال الجديد
الى متى يمكن ان تستمر وكيف ستكون شدتها
شدتها علميا طبعا لن اتحدث عن توقعات ولكن
في علم الزلازل
ما هي الفتره التي يمكن ان تستمر فيها
كذلك الهزات الارتداديه وشدتها المتوقعه
كذلك
هلا كل زلزال يختلف عن الاخر يعني قد
تستمر الى فتره اسبوعين ثلاثه اربعه شهر
ولكن ما نشاهد اليوم انه
الارتداديه بلشت من اربعه بينما زلزال
السادس من فبراير احنا شاهدنا انه زلزال
قوه سته وسبعه بالعشره بعد 11 دقيقه من
الزلزال اللي حصل الساعه الرابعه عشر
دقيقه يعني انه تقريبا يعني زلزال سته
وسبعه بالعشره بعد زلزال سبعه وثمانيه من
عشره انت اليوم تتكلم عن زلزال سته او
ثلاثه
ولحقوا زلزال يعني يا دوب الناس شعرت
بناته من اثنين في اختلاف ولكن 85 بالعشره
وعلى طول بلشنا نلاحظ انه زلازل قوه ثلاثه
ونصف واربعه فهذا لازم ان شاء الله تعتبر
سلاسل غير مدمره وان شاء الله يعني تهدا
الامور باسرع ارجو ان تبقى معي استاذ غسان
سنحن بحاجه الى تفسيراتك
بشكل كبير هذه الليله ساعود اليك في سياق
ضمن هذه التغطيه المستمره اذا عاجل اخر
الان مشاهدينا تشاهدون على الشاشه مدير
الخطوط الجويه التركيه لا اضرار في مدرج
مطار هاتاي بعد الزلزال الجديد كان هناك
معلومات على انه
حركه طيران توقفت في مطار هاتاي بعد هذا
الزلزال الجديد نتابع الصوره اذا الان من
ادلب مع مراسل العربيه مسلم السيد عيسى
مسلم اهلا بك معنا
الخوذ البيضاء تحدثت عن 130 مصاب في شمال
غرب سوريا هل هناك اي معطيات جديده
نعم مساء الخير يعني حقيقه الاصابات
تتواصل الى المستشفيات هنا في مناطق
الشمال سوريا واغلبها وهو الجدير بالذكر
انها حالات هلع وخوف وايضا حالات كسور
بسبب رمي الاشخاص انفسهم من شرف منازلهم
وهذا حقيقه ما يعني العلامه الفارقه الان
في هذا الزلزال ان حاله الهلع والخوف هي
المسيطره على المشهد الان يعني كل الاهالي
في المنطقه نزلت الى الشوارع وهي بحاله
هلع وخوف شديده انا يعني كنت في الزلزال
الاول والثاني ما شاهدته اليوم كان مختلفا
حقيقه حاله الرعب شديده جدا الاطفال في
حاله في حاله نفسيه شديده ايضا كبار السن
وغيرهم من الحالات المزمنه وبالتالي يعني
المميز الان هو حاله الهلع والخوف ما
رفضناه حتى اللحظه هو اكثر من 55 مصاب
بسبب رمي انفسهم من شرفات المنازل في شمال
غرب سوريا وايضا في منطقه الاتارب بشكل
خاص
التي كانت تضررت بفعل الزلزال
ساعود اليكم مسلم
ارجل مباشره من مركز الزلزال الجديد في
هاتاي جنوب تركيا ايضا مراسل العربيه
زيدان زين كلو زيدان اهلا بك اخر التفاصيل
والمشهد من عندك
فورا صهيب سانتقل الى المشهد كما تشاهد
فرق الانقاذ وصلنا معها قبل قليل الى هذا
المبنى الذي انهار قبل قليل بسبب الزلزال
الجديد هنا في منطقه دفنه في مدينه
انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي فرق الانقاذ فور
وصولها احضرت كلاب مدربه الى هذا الموقع
للتاكد مما اذا كان هناك اشخاص على قيد
الحياه ام لا الكلاب لم تعطي اي اشاره على
وجود اشخاص على قيد الحياه لذلك الان
انتقلت عمليه البحث الى مرحله اخرى
سيحاولون التاكد في حال كان هناك شخص ما
موجود تحت الانقاض او جثه او ما شابه لذلك
هذا المبنى بالعموم كما تشاهد انهارا وهو
مبنى متصدع في هذه المنطقه الان استدعوا
رجال الاطفاء تحت هذا المبنى في الطابق
الارضي الذي انهار كان هناك حريق
كان اندلع بعد هبوط هذا المبنى هذا هذا
الحي بالكامل تقريبا المدمر او فيه مباني
متصدعه بشكل كبير وهذا احد المباني الذي
انهار نتيجه الزلزال الجديد طبعا الحصيله
بحسب او حصيله الضحايا ضحايا الزلزال جديد
بحسب ما اعلنه وزير الداخليه سليمان سويلو
ثلاثه قتلى احدهم هنا في منطقه دفنه في
هاتاي وشخص اخر في سمندار وايضا شخص
والشخص الثالث في مركز ولايه هاتاي او في
مركز انطاكيا اضافه الى 213 جريحا هم
يتلقون العلاج الان في المشافي كما نتابع
معكم مباشره هذه اللقطات فرق الانقاذ وفرق
الاطفال تحاول اطفاق حريق كان في الطابق
الارضي الطابق الذي انهار
وهذا طابق يعني كان على ما اعتقد ثلاثه
طوابق او هذا مؤلف من ثلاثه طوابق الان
الطابق انهارا والان طيب فرق الانقاذ
تحاول الت تسمح لي فقط موجود اي شخص تحت
الانقاذ
زيدان اسمحلي فقط اذا مشاهدينا العربيه في
مركز الزلزال الجديد صور مباشره مع
مراسلنا اذا من دفنه بمدينه انطاكيا مركز
ولايه هاتاي في جنوب تركيا مركز الزلزال
الجديد هذا هو الحدث الابرز هذه الليله
العربيه حاضره هناك كما تتابعون في هذه
الصور المباشره الزلزال الجديد بلغت شدته
6.4 درجات على مقياس ريختر وتلهوا زلزال
اخر بشده 5.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر اوقع
حتى الان ثلاثه قتلى حسب وزير الداخليه
التركي سليمان سويلم واكثر من مئتين
وثلاثه عشر
جريحا اذا صور مباشره من دفنه في مدينه
انطاكيا عاصمه او مركز ولايه هاتاي
التركيه زيدان اعود اليك مره اخرى كنت
تتحدث عن حريق اندلع في هذا المبنى الذي
انهار ما كان سبب الحريق وهل الفرق هذه
يعني تشتبه في وجود شخص عالق تحت هذه
الانقاض ام فقط هم يتاكدون من سلامه
المبنى او من عدم سقوطه نهائيا ام ماذا
نعم وصلنا الى المبنى قبل حوالي عشر دقائق
لا نعلم بالضبط سبب الحريق هل كان هناك
اشخاص قد اشعلوا مدفاه ام لا لكن لا نعلم
بالضبط سبب الحريق لكن تم اطفاء الحريق في
هذا المبنى فرق الانقاذ كما تحدثت صهيب
قبل قليل احضرت كلاب مدربه الى هذا المكان
للتاكد من وجود اشخاص ان كانوا على قيد
الحياه ام لا لكن الكلاب المدربه لم تعطي
اي استجابه وبالتالي انسحبوا الى موقع اخر
بقيت هنا فرق الانقاذ تحاول التاكد من
وجود اي اشخاص قد فارقوا الحياه لا قدر
الله لا سمح الله نتمنى ان لا يحدث هذا
السيناريو الان يحاولون ابعادنا عن هذا
المبنى كما تشاهد هناك خطوره من انهيارات
جديده يطلبون الابتعاد قليلا نعم لكن كما
تابعنا فرق الانقاذ تحاول التاكد سواء من
هذا المبنى او المباني المجاوره فقط ايضا
صهيب وليس هذا المبنى مره اخرى نحن نحن
نقول مع هذه الصوره الحيه اذا من مركز
الزلز وهذا المبنى الذي انهار قبل لحظات
العربيه اذا في مركز الزلزال مراسلنا وصل
الى عين المكان اذا قبل عشر دقائق من الان
فرق الانقاذ اخمدت حريقا اندلع في هذا
المبنى وهي
ربما تتاكد من عدم وجود اي اشخاص عالقين
تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى في العاجل الان
ولايه مرسينا تركيا تعلن تعطيل المدارس
غدا بعد الزلزال
جديد كنا سمعنا كذلك
بان في لبنان ايضا على ما يبدو هناك تعطيل
للمدارس غدا بسبب الزلزال الجديد حالتها
العك كذلك تم رصدها في لبنان وفي فلسطين
والاردن بعد هذه الهزه وفي سوريا طبعا
سوريا الاكثر شعرت بالزلزال بشكل كبير جدا
بالنظر الى انه هاتاي قريبه جدا من الحدود
السوريه وهي كانت جزءا اصلا من اراضي
السوريه هي اللواء اسكندرون
زيدان ذكرت لي انه الفرق طلبت منك
الابتعاد قليلا هل هناك خشيه يعني من هذا
المب بناء ان ينهار كليا
طبعا لا صهيب لاسيما ان الهزات الارتداديه
ما زالت متواصله تم تسجيل اكثر من 26 هزا
ارتداديه بعد الزلزال الذي وقع في تمام
الساعه الثامنه واربع دقائق في مساء
بالتوقيت المحلي كما تشاهد هذا المبنى
ساحاول واطلب من زميلي تصوير هذا المبنى
والمباني المجاوره التي اما تصدعت او
انهار قسم منها بالتالي طلبوا الابتعاد
قليلا خصوصا من الطواقم الصحفيه لكن مع
ذلك لنحاول ان نبقى هنا في هذا المكان
لنرصد لكم مباشره كل ما يجري هنا في هاتاي
وفي تحديدا في مدينه انطاكيا في منطقه
دفنه حيث كانت مركز الزلزال كما تحدثنا
يعني اليوم هو خلال وصولنا حقيقه كان من
الصعب الوصول الى هنا
صهيب بسبب حركه سيارات الاسعاف وفرق طواقم
الانقاذ على الطرق ايضا كان هناك مخاطر
يعني كثيره على الطرق والجسور على نهر
العاصفه في مدينه انطاكيا عندما وصلنا
كانت الشرطه قد وضعت حاجزا على احد الجسور
فوق نهر العاصي تحذر او منعه بشكل كامل اي
سياره من الاقتراب او عبور فوق هذا الجسر
خوفا من اي انهيارات اثناء هزات ارتداديه
شاهدنا تضررا في الطرق هنا في انطاكيا نحن
كنا في انطاكيا طيله هذا اليوم غادرناها
في تمام الساعه السابعه اي قبل ساعه واحده
فقط من وقوع الزلزال عندما عدنا اليها
مساء هذا اليوم بعد الزلزال شاهدنا ضررا
اضافيا في الطرق التي كنا قد مررنا بها
ظهر هذا اليوم وعصر هذا اليوم ايضا هناك
ضرر في بعض كما ذكرت الجسور فوق نهر
العاصي للمعلومه فقط نهر العاصي يخترق
مدينه انطاكيا لذلك هناك بعض الجسور
للسيارات
نهر العاصي تربط بين طرفي المدينه هناك
الشرطه والجيش اغلقت بعض هذه الجسور خوفا
من انهيارات
وتصدعات حتى الان لم يتم التاكد من سلامه
هذه الجسور من قبل الفرق المختصه لذلك تم
اغلاق بعض الجسور الطيران المروحي كان قبل
قليل في سماء انطاكيا يساع يساعد ايضا في
عمليه المراقبه
والتعقب ايضا مع فرق الانقاذ وهم على
تواصل مباشر مع غرفه عمليات هنا في قرب
مركز افات حيث تم اخلاء المركز قبل قليل
حيث كان وزير الصحه والدفاع في المركز وتم
اخلاقه قبل قليل وزير الداخليه ايضا كان
في طريقه الى هاتاي للتاكد او لمتابعه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ صهيب خبر عاجل جديد
اذا هذه المره بالنسبه لسوريه ارتفاع
حصيله المصابين جراء الزلزال الجديد الى
470 مصابا جراء الجديد اذا نقلا عن المرصد
السوري
زيدان نحن باقون معك ومع هذه الصوره الحيه
اذا من مركز الزلزال الجديد من منطقه دفنه
بمدينه انطاكيا مركز ولايه هاتاي نحن
نتابع معكم هذا المبنى الذي انهار جراء
هذا الزلزال الجديد مراسلنا وصل الى هناك
قبل فتره وجيزه قبل يعني حوالي ربع ساعه
اذا من الان ونشاهد معه فرق الانقاذ وهي
التي قامت باخماد حريق اخبرنا ايضا زيدان
قبل قليل بانها نجحت في من اخماد هذا
الحريق وهي تحاول تاكد من عدم وجود ضحايا
عالقين او اشخاص عالقين تحت انقاض هذا
المبنى المرصد السوري يقول انهيار وتصدع
بعض المباني في جنديرس والاتارب جراء
الزلزال الجديد معنا رامي عبد الرحمن مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان استاذ رامي
الحصيله ترتفع 470 مصابا هل نتحدث عن
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا فقط من كل الاراضي
السوريه
استاذ ربيع عبد الرحمن
رامي عبد الرحمن هل تسمعني
طيب يبدو ان ضيفي لا يسمعني اعود الى مسلم
السيد عيسى مراسل العربيه من ادلب مسلم
كنت تتحدث مسلم هل تسمعني
نعم كنت تتحدث لي قبل قليل ان غالبيه
المصابين في رفق ادلب مثلا كان هناك عدد
كبير من المصابين من الذين القوا بانفسهم
من النوافذ بعد شعورهم بالهزه خوفا وهلعن
من هذه
الهزه
اخبرني كذلك عن المزيد من المعطيات حول
هؤلاء المصابين وكذلك عن حجم الاضرار
المسجله حتى الان عندكم في ريف ادلب
نعم يعني حتى هذه اللحظه ما سجل هو وسقوط
12 مبنى في بلدات حارم وسلقين والاتارب
وايضا بلده جنديرس هذه المباني هي كانت
الهائله ومهدده بالسقوط ويبدو انها تاثرت
بفعل هذا الزلزال بالنسبه للمدن التي لم
تصبها اضرار جسيمه سقطت بعض النوافذ
وواجهات المباني وغيرها ما تسبب بجروح لدى
سكان المنطقه الذين كانوا في الشوارع
المؤكد حتى اللحظه هي 55 اصابه فقط ممن
القوا بانفسهم من النوافل ومن شرفات
منازلهم نتيجه الخوف والهلع نتحدث عن رقم
حقيقه كبير مقارنه ب 130 اصابه في شمال
غرب سوريا حتى اللحظه الرقم مرجح طبعا
بشكل كبير للزياده لان لا تزال هناك توافق
كبير على المستشفيات في المناطق الداخليه
من شمال غرب سوريا لان المستشفيات هناك
هناك نقطه مهمه للمستشفيات التي كانت
متواجده في المناطق التي تضررت بشكل كبير
بفعل زلزال على الحدود السوريه التركيه
يبدو انها سيتم اخلائها خلال الساعات
القليله القادمه لانها كانت اصلا متضرره
متفضعه وكانت تقوم بعمليات الاخلاء العاجل
او الاسعافات الاوليه في خيام وضعت على
ابواب هذه المستشفيات ثم يتم نقل
المصابين الى المستشفيات الداخليه الامنه
نسبيا فبالتالي نتحدث عن ايضا يعني تدرس
القطاع الصحي بشكل مباشر نتيجه التخوفات
من انهيار ايضا هذه المستشفيات يعني مركز
مدينه تلقين يبعد تماما عن مركز مدينه
انطاكيا بحدود تقريبا ال 20 كلم وبالتالي
هو قريب جدا تعتبر جزء من هذه
الولايه بشكل تقريبي وبالتالي تضررت بشكل
كبير
والاضرار حقيقه ستبدا مع يعني طلوع فجر
يوم غد بالتكشف بشكل حقيقي كما ذكرت الذين
اصيبوا فقط من من القوا بانفسهم من شرفات
منازلهم هم 55 شخص وبالتالي هذا دليل مؤشر
كبير على حاله الهلع والخوف الذي يصيب
سكان المنطقه هنا انا يعني اشاهد من
العالي نزلت الى الشوارع قالت اننا لا
نريد ان نعود الى المنازل سنبقى في العراق
سنبقى في اي مكان بسبب الخوف الذي
يشاهدونه بعيون اطفالهم وكبار السن الذين
معهم نعم مسلم انت باقي معنا في هذه
التغطيه ايضا مشاهدينا أعود واذكر هذه
الصور خاصه للعربيه مباشره من منطقه دفنه
من انطاكيا مركز ولايه هاتايم مركز
الزلزال الجديد الذي تسبب حتى الان في
مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه اكثر من 213 شخصا
نشاهد معكم فرق افاد التركيه وهي هيئه
الكوارث اداره الكوارث والازمات التابعه
للداخليه التركيه
نعم والان على ذكر اداره الكوارث هي تتحدث
عن تسجيل اثنتين هزه ابتداديه الان زلزال
الجديد وهناك دخان يتصاعد نشاهده معكم على
الهواء مباشره
مراسلنا الذي وصل الى عين المكان قبل قليل
اكد ان فرق الانقاذ نجحت في اخماد حريق في
هذا المبنى قبل ان ينهار او بعد ان انهار
بسبب الزلزال الجديد الذي بلغت شدته 6.4
درجات على مقياس سنختر وكان مركزه من هذه
المدينه من مدينه انطاكيا عاصمه ولايه
هاتاي في جنوب تركيا على الحدود السوريه
نشاهد فرق الانقاذ هي كما ذكرها مراسلنا
قبل قليل استقدمت كلابا للبحث عن اشخاص
للتاكد من وجود اشخاص او لا تحت انقاض هذا
المبنى الذي اندلعت فيه نيران ونجحت فرق
الاطفاء
في
يعني في
اخماده طبعا هذه الصور مباشره من منطقه
دفنه بالتحديد في مدينه انطاكيا
اعود واذكر ان حجم الرعب
والدمار كذلك في سوريا كان كبيرا جدا كما
استمعنا قبل قليل مراسل العربيه في ريف
ادلب تحدث عن القاء حوالي 51 شخص لانفسهم
من النوافذ بسبب الخوف والهلع من الزلزال
ما ادى الى اصابه بكسور وجروح وتم نقلهم
الى المستشفى كان هناك انهيار 12 مبنى في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا هذا المساء جراء
هذين الزلزالين الجديدين
وللاسف يعني ما زالت الهزات الارتداديه
تسجل اثنتان وثلاثون هزه
ارتداديه جديده جرى تسجيلها حتى الان بعد
الزلزلين
الجديدين اذا
اذكر بان الزلزال يعني قوي نسبيا سته فاصل
اربعه درجات على مقياس ريختر طبعا شعرت به
المناطق السوريه بشكل كبير جدا حتى في
لبنان كان هناك حاله هلع بعد ان شعر
السكان بهذا الزلزال الجديد بالنظر الى
انه اقرب بكثير عن الزلزال الاول زلزال
السادس من فبراير بحوالي 250 كيلومتر كنا
نتحدث عن زلزال مركزه كرمان مرعش الان
هاتاي هي اقرب بكثير الى الحدود السوريه
على العموم معنى الان من بيروت غنويتم
مراسله العربيه غنوه هل ما يزال الناس
خائفين او خائفون بعد هذا الزلزال الجديد
الذي شعره به في بيروت
نعم صهيب لا يزال هناك خوف لدى المواطنين
ولا يزال عدد منهم في في العرب في الاماكن
البعيده من الابنيه خاصه سكان الابنيه
القديمه هم يعني لا يخشون من قوه الهزه
لكن يقصون بان حتى ان كانت هزه خفيفه مع
تكرار هذه الهزات بان يكون هناك سقوط
لمباني او امور مشابهه ايضا كان هناك بيان
من وزاره التربيه صدر ريان طلب في غدا
جميع المدارس والمؤسسات التربويه
والجامعات بالاطفال غدا وبالقيام
بالتاكد من سلامه الابنيه قبل عوده قبل
عوده التلامذه يوم الاربعاء خوفا من ان
يكون هناك اي ارتدادات علما بان الخبراء
الجيولوجيين في لبنان مركز بحمص كان قد
اصدر قبل حوالي الساعه بيان رسمي حول
الموضوع وهو قال بان الهزه هي يعني هزه
ارتداديه عما حدث في تركيا وليست هزه
داخليه وايضا يعني كان هناك اشاعات صارت
بين المواطنين بانه يمكن ان يكون هناك
موجات تسونامي في لبنان تحدثوا عن تراجع
مياه البحر ايضا
بانه لا يخوف من تسونامي في لبنان ولكن
بالطبع صهيب كما قلت يعني العالم
المواطنون اليوم يشعرون بالخوف والر بعد
المشاهد التي شاهدوها في في تركيا ايضا
بالطبع يعني المواطنين المواطنين في
طرابلس ايضا في الشمال كان هناك حاله من
الهلع اكثر من من العاصمه بيروت وكان هناك
خروج لعدد كبير من المواطنين يعني اقرب
رد الفعل هذا هو رد فعل مشابه بعد كل هذا
يشعر فيها المواطنين في لبنان نعم غنوه
ارجو ان تبقي معي لا اعلم اذا كان ضيفي من
عمان ما يزال معنا
السيد غسان السويدان رئيس مركز رصد
الزلازل الاردني طبعا استاذ غسان انت تعلم
في حالات الخوف هذه والهلع جراء الزلازل
كما تبعنا مراسلنا قبل قليل كان يتحدث عن
اناس وصل بهم الخوف والهلع لانهم عايشوا
الزلزال الاول الى القاء انفسهم من نوافذ
او من الشروفات ما ادى الى اصابتهم بكسور
ولكن انا اريد ان اسالك عن العالم
الهولندي الذي اثار الجدل بفرنك هوجربيس
كان كذلك توقع على ما يبدو كما كما اشاهد
الان توقع فيها وقوع هزات جديده في
المنطقه
يبدو انه مره اخرى صدقه توقعه بحوالي 24
ساعه تقريبا
هل يمكن
التنبؤ بالزلازل ام لا
سيدي يعني انا باكد لك مليون بالمئه انه
قد تتوقع زلزال مناطق نشطه الزلزاليه تقول
والله انه ممكن يصير فيها زلزال ولكن
موضوع التنبؤ يعني هذا موضوع غير علمي
وغير دقيق وليس مثبت انا لا اعلم بالضبط
ما هي تغريده هذا العالم الهولندي ولكن
باكدك مليون بالمئه انه ما في شيء اسمه
تنبؤ بالزلازل كل ما حصل هو بالضبط في
التغريده ماذا قال الفتره نعم هو ماذا قال
امام التغريد الان قال قد يحدث نشاط
زلزالي اقوى في الفتره من 20 الى 22
فبراير تقريبا ومن المحتمل ان يبلغ ذروته
في يوم الثاني والعشرين
واليوم عاد غرد نفس التغريده وكتب عليها
نشره الامس في حال انكم لم تروها
يعني صدقا انني لم اتابعه نعم
يعني هو هذه المره لم يتحدث عن قوه
الزلزال تحدث عن الفتره من 20 الى 22 يعني
الزلزال وقع يوم 20 ونحن الان عمليا بعد
12 بالليل دخلنا في يوم 21 فبراير
صحيح صحيح
لا اعلم سيدي عن جد انا يعني لا اعلم بهذا
الشيء وانا يعني متاكد منه انه ما في شيء
لا مبني على اسس علميه ولا اسس حتى يعني
مرتبطه بالفضاء او الاقمار الصناعيه او
بالنجوم والى اخره يعني
تنبؤ بالزلازل هذا موضوع غير علمي نهائيا
نعم
طيب ولكن ذكر على انه مثلا اليابان طورت
اليات علميه للتنبؤ بالزلازل ولكن صحيح
ربما قبل قبل الزلزال بثواني معدوده يعني
انه ممكن او حتى دقيقه حتى يتم قطع الغاز
حتى لا تندلع الحرائق جراء الزلزال وكذلك
توقيف حركه القطارات حتى لا تحدث اضرار
يعني هل هذه كيف يتم التنبؤ بالزلازل هنا
في هذه الحاله
تمام تمام هو ليس تنبا يعني عندما يحصل
عنا زلزال تنتشر عده امواج عده انواع من
الامواج الزلزاليه هناك نسميها امواج
اوليه وهناك امواج ثانويه الامواج الاوليه
تسبق الامواج الثانويه تقريبا بواحد وسبعه
بالعشره يعني تقريبا الضعف فانت لما بتوصل
عندك الامواج الاوليه اللي هي غير مدمره
فانت بتكون عارف انه انا رح توصلني
الامواج العرضانيه او الامواج الثانويه
بعد مثلا خمس دقائق او لا عفوا اقل من هيك
فحسب بعد الزلزال عن المنطقه خلينا نقول
فهم بيعرفوا مثلا اذا وصلتني هاي الموجه
فانا بروح بعمل الشوت داون
نعم من مراسلتنا في بيروت يعني وزاره
التعليم اللبنانيه اعلنا التوقيف المدارس
غدا
هل ترى انه واجب يعني كذلك على يعني باقي
الدول او باقي المناطق
يعني هل ترى في هذا اجراء سليما
يوم غد يعني حتى لا يكون هناك ممكن ان
يكون هناك هزات قد توقع اضرار برايك اعلم
انه لا يمكن التنبؤ بالزلازل ولكن هل ترى
يعني انه من الواجب ضمن الاجراءات تعطيل
الدراسه في المدارس والجامعات غدا
اكيد تمام يعني هو يا سيدي دائما ابدا في
هاي المواقف يفضل انك اتخاذ الاجراء
الاسوا او انه يعني انه لا سمح الله
العطله شيء كويس نعم بالضبط احتمال الاسوا
وليس الاحتمال الافضل
تعطيني مدارس خاصه انه بعد هذه الليله
عاشوا الاهالي صعب جدا انه الطلاب صباحا
يستعدوا يذهبوا الى المدارس فبدك انت اكيد
انه في راح يكون في اجراءات وقايه انه
يتاكدوا من وضعيه المدارس انه ما صار فيها
يعني تشققات او امور قد تسبب الطلبه
فان شاء الله ما يكون في هذه الامور
السيئه
وكل شيء تمام وترجع الدراسه وترجع الحياه
الى طبيعتها
ارجو ان تبقى معنا اذا مشاهدينا اعود
واذكر هذه الصور التي تشاهدون هي صور خاصه
للعربيه من مركز الزلزال بالتحديد من
منطقه دفنه في انطاكيا مركز ولايه هاتاي
وهي مركز الزلزلين الجديدين الذين هزاع
جنوب تركيا طبعا
وكذلك مناطق سوريا وحتى في لبنان شعر
السكان بهذه الهزه القويه
مراسلنا هناك في دفنه منذ فتره لا اعلم
اذا كنت
تسمعني زيدان زنكلو
زيدان لا يسمعني ولكن نحن نراقب هذه الصور
هناك جرافات على ما يبدو تتقدم باتجاه
المبنى الذي انهار قبل قليل جراء هذا
الزلزال الجديد
لا نعلم اذا كانت تحاول اخراج شيء ما او
يعني التاكد سنشاهد معكم هذه الصور اذا
جرافه تتقدم
باتجاه هذا المبنى الذي انهار قبل قليل
جراء الزلزال الجديد مركزه اذن انطاكيا
مركز ولايه هاتاي كما نتابع معكم هذه
الصور المباشره فرق افادا تابعه لهيئه
اداره الكوارث والازمات التركيه
هذا المبنى كان شهد اندلاع حريق هناك في
منطقه دفنه
وجرى اخماده قبل قليل اعود واذكر حصيله
الضحايا حتى الان ثلاثه قتلى في تركيا 213
جريحا حتى الان حسب اخر تحديث لوزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان اما في الاراضي
السوريه فالحصيله 470 مصابا وهناك عدد
كبير كما ذكر مراسلنا قبل قليل المريخ
ادلب من المصابين اصابتهم جراء القاء
انفسهم من الشرفات ومن النوافذ بعد شعورهم
بهذا الزلزال الجديد خوفا طبعا وهلعا
وهربا من هذا الزلزال وانهيار 12 مبنى في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا على العموم معنا
الان رامي عبد الرحمن مدير المرصد السوري
للحقوق الانسان والسيد رامي تسمعني
الحصيله ما تزال عندها 470 مصابا نعم
واربع حالات وفاه في مناطق النظام نتيجه
حالات الهلع اسنان في حلب واحده في حماه
وحدت في محافظه طرطوس نتيجه حالات واحتشاء
العضله القلبيه الخوف من الزلزال والدفاع
والتدافع
استاذ عبد الرحمن دعني دعني اتحقق من
الخبر اربعه قتله اذا في سوريا
قتله في سوريا جراء الزلزال
هناك هناك وفاتين في حلب وفاه في حماه
وفاه في
محافظه الهلع واحتشاء العضله القلبيه
نتيجه الخوف حالات
اصبحت نتيجه بعضها كسور بعضها نتيجه
تسببت تسببت فيها هذا الزلزال الشديد
هذا شيء مخيف يعني هناك حالات كسور وحالات
تدافع طبعا هذا يسبب الوفاه ولكن من الخوف
من الزلزال يمكن ان يسبب الوفاه يعني ازمه
نتيجه ازمه قلبيه هناك حاله وفاه على
الاقل كما ذكرت نتيجه ازمه قلبيه
حلب لوحده عندما تحدث النظام عن 47 هذا
كانت في مشفى الرازي لوحده
هناك حالات كثيره في محافظه اللاذقيه
محافظه حماه ايضا نتيجه الانتفاع والنتيجه
ظهرت الى الشوارع كان هناك حوادث سير وقعت
حقيقه قمر سواء في مناطق سيطره المع مناطق
سيطره النظام يعني حاله الرعب التي عاشها
ابناء الشعب السوري بعد يعني هذا الزلزال
الجديد كانت مخيفه جدا يعني
كذلك عن المناطق اللي على الساحل السوري
لانه
هاتاي طبعا اللواء اسكندرون سابقا هي اقرب
الى تلك المنطقه يعني هي داخله في في
العمق السوري هل من معلومات عن الوضع في
الساحل السوري في مناطق الساحل لانه هي
الاقرب الى هاتاي اكثر من مئه وعشرين حاله
اصابه من الاصابات هي في محافظه اللاذقيه
لوحدها محافظه اللاذقيه
اللاذقيه بن ريف اللاذقيه 120 حاله اصابه
وفي بالياس كان هناك تشقق في المنازل
حقيقه الامر الان هناك منازل في الزلزال
الاول لم يسبها شيء اليوم كان نتيجه
جديد تشقق في بعض المنازل نتيجه
التاثير كان في الساحل اكثر من مناطق اخرى
في حاله تساقطت مباني او نهارا بشكل جزئي
في عده احياء من حلب ولكن لم يكن داخلها
اي مواطن وهذا شيء كان يعني
جنبنا سقوط مفيد من الضحايا ولكن مع الاسف
حالات التي كانت اكبر حتى في ادلب كان
هناك رمي من يعني البعض يقرب القفز من
الشرفات المنازل نتيجه الخوف البعض نتيجه
تدافع ايضا سقطت عليه احجره حجاره
بالمباني التي تهدمت اي ان الحالات هي
اكثر من هذه الارقام التي تحدثنا منها
عليها فهناك في بعض المناطق لم نستطيع
الوصول اليها حقيقه الامر الغريب استاذ
رامي اننا بيتنا نسجل قتل جراء الهلع
والخوف من الزلزال يعني هذا شيء يعني لا
اعلم كيف يمكن ان نصفه على العموم نحن
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا الصور من مركز
الزلزال الجديد من منطقه دف
بانطاكيا مركز ولايه هاتاي كاميرا العربيه
ترصد معكم الان على الهواء مباشره هذا
المبنى المنهار طبعا نتابع معكم هذه
الجرافه التي تحاول ازاله الركام بعد ان
اخمدت حريقا اندلع في هذا المبنى والذي
انهار جراء الزلزال الجديد الذي بلغت شدته
6.4 درجات على مقياس
اذا مشاهدينا حتى اجمل لكم اخر التطورات
التي رصدناها معكم خلال هذه الساعه من
تغطيتنا المستمره على العربيه ثلاثه قتلى
اذا في تركيا 213 مصابا جراء الزلزالين
جديدين كان مركزهما في انطاكيا عاصمه
ولايه هاتاي في جنوب تركيا على الحدود
السوريه هاتاي سابقا هي كانت لواء
اسكندرون كانت تابعه
للاراضي السوريه حتى عام 39 ايام الانتداب
الفرنسي وبالتالي هي منطقه قريبه جدا الى
سوريا في سوريا كان هناك حاله هلع ورعب
كبيرين كما تبعنا معكم الحصيله اربعه قتله
في سوريا كما ذكر المصدر السوري للعربيه
470 مصابا وتضرر العديد من المباني هذه
الهزه الجديده هذا الزلزال الجديد وصل
تاثيره الى
لبنان والى الاردن والى فلسطين كذلك
وزاره التعليم اللبنانيه اعلنت تعطيل
المدارس غدا
تجنبا لاي سيناريو سيء كان هناك حاله هلع
كبيره طبعا في لبنان بعد شعور الناس
بالهزه وخروجهم الى الشوارع وكما تبعنا
معكم كان هناك حاله هلع كبيره في مناطق
الشمال السوري خصوصا وطبعا تسجيل هذا
العدد من المصابين